of course he lost Colton on the show
this season what's that like for you and
do you think we'll see him back or do
you think you'll be in the legends of
tomorrow I mean there is always a bunch
of possibilities of what can happen I
would love for him to be there
absolutely love working with him more
than anything so yeah just high hopes
really of course we saw you go into the
Lazarus Pit and be resurrected and we
know this has had an effect on you we
might not seem that full effect yet do
you think there's a chance how much per
chance you think there is in future we
might see say an evil seer for example I
mean I've always thought it'd be really
funny if Thea had an evil twin somewhere
like just or if it just was spawned out
of the Lazarus Pit all of a sudden
there's just like evil twin it's pops up
but like I don't know a couple episodes
and it'll be really cool but as far as
effects of the Lazarus Pit go I mean
there hasn't really been too many since
soon as she got out and came back I mean
she kind of was a little dopey at first
but then came back to herself so I can
only hope that there's gonna be some fun
stuff to play with but again I really
don't know how I don't have an answer
for that and finally what would you like
to see happen with Damian dark who had
teased in the last episode ahaha i would
like to see a lot of things happen with
that character but i mean cuz Damian
isn't that that's Batman's yeah Demi
Wayne yeah I mean again anything had
happened anything is possible although
we saw you die this season what would
you like to see happen for your future
if you came back go straight into her
sword
hmm yeah I would love that
you